hello and welcome to a week 10 edition
of The Bleacher Report fantasy football
show presented by State Farm my name is
Adam Levitan of establish the run.com as
always joined by Michael Leone of
establish the run.com Michael tell the
people what Jersey you're wearing today
they're probably too young to even know
who this is and how are you doing today
got the uh Reggie Reggie White Fly
Eagles Fly Jersey here old school of
course you know what it is being from
Philly
so beautiful Kelly Green Reggie White
Jersey there on Leone on today's show we
know a lot of you have many guys on by
this week a lot of stars on by this week
Dolphins no Eagles no so we are going to
come up with some guys that we think are
good plays to replace some of these
stars for your season long lineup or
maybe your DFS lineup will also do our
bundles of the week and today is a
gauntlet
show Gauntlet means producer Ian is
going to try to stump us try to
challenge us is it our guys that we're
saying here as starts or is it someone
that he has come up with that we prefer
better so let's go ahead and hop right
into it here
with our best starts with stars on a buy
this week let's start with Deandre
Hopkins Leoni now a lot of different
things going on with the Titans will
Levis gets the chance with Ryan tanah
Hill hurt and looks pretty good and not
pretty good I thought looks actually
really good aggressive throw in the
football down the field has a massive
arm I mean one of those guys who like
just kind of flicks it and it goes
really far you saw him two weeks ago
just give DeAndre Hopkins a chance go
long throw it up there and give him a
chance that's not what Ryan tanah Hill's
game really has been in his career and
then this week you get DeAndre Hopkins
against the pass funneling bucks defense
we saw what CJ Stroud tank Dell Dalton
Schultz niiko Collins were able to do to
them last week I think it's gonna be a
struggle for Derrick Henry and Taj spear
toine efficiency here against this bucks
front and so Levis to Hopkins is the new
wave shall I take on The Gauntlet
here
give it to
me oh God just goes right for the jugler
with one of my favorite players so so
Brandon auka is playing the Jaguars this
week Deo Samuel is indeed uh expected
back however guy is just good at the
game I mean I don't think people really
realize how good he is this is a close
one we have Brandon iuk about
0.7 points ahead but in the in the name
of the gauntlet I'm going to ikb I know
better this one I'm going to stick with
DeAndre Hopkins over Brandon auk with
Debo Samuel back here give me another
one oh God Adam th in the game tonight
against the Bears so we saw Adam thielen
come crashing back to Earth last night
perhaps in predictable fashion you know
felt like last week was the stone cold
top of Adam thielen but now you're
talking about a Bears defense which I
think is also a bit is so I will go
Thelen over Hopkins here it's hard to
pass on seven eight n very catchable
targets so give me Thelen over Hopkins
here all right Leone you can take on
your your first Gauntlet yeah we'll go
Demario Douglas here for the New England
Patriots they're having all sorts of
problems with their pass catchers in
terms of health whatnot and availability
so Demario Douglas back-to-back weeks
with seven targets for the Patriots he's
not like a huge ceiling guy but in a
full PPR League he's going to get a
really high catch rate I think on these
targets facing a Colts team that
inflates opposition plays as well so I
think we can see an increase in
dropbacks for M Jones and the Patriots
which will funnel to Deo Douglas who
should lead this team in Target shares
so yeah let's go bring on the gaunlet
for
me
jacobe
Meyers um oh
man let's see here I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go Douglas here uh Myers has had
an incredible role all season long but I
think there's just a little bit more
variance with Aiden oconnell at
quarterback you know they've really made
a point to get the ball to Devonte Adams
run it more with Josh Jacobs I'll take
Demario Douglas here I think New England
will have more pass attempts than
vus
next Drake
London oh man I'll proba I'll probably
you know can can see the gauntlet here
I'll go Drake London it gets tougher
with with each one but I think on a
talent perspective like London's just on
a different tier than Douglas and jacobe
Meyers and you just got to roll with him
um even as frustrating as the Atlanta
offense can be yeah
and also I would say that with Taylor
hinei I think they are more likely to
get the ball down the field and that's
certainly a good thing for uh Drake
London there one thing for me on Dem
Douglas is playing not just slot now but
playing inside and outside so he's
playing almost every snap really good
role right now for de Douglas third guy
is a guy that oh my gosh people are out
of control on bejon Robinson right now
I've gotten so many questions can I drop
bejan Robinson do I have to start bejan
Robinson who can I get get rid of bejan
Robinson for not only that but finally
like the Atlanta media is getting all
over Arthur Smith about his usage of
bean Robinson I mean they are peppering
him he's giving like 10-minute diet
tribes now defending why Tyler alir and
jnu Smith are getting goal line carries
ahead of bejan Robinson as their Red
Zone success rate continues to plummet
so there's a lot going on with bejan
Robinson here I feel like people are
queasy about playing him there's going
to be a Tipping Point I think soon
Arthur Smith has making the general
manager just look bad I mean he spent
the number eight overall pick on bjon
Robinson he's not getting used so you're
embarrassing your front office you're
embarrassing your team so there's gonna
be a Tipping Point here soon I'm okay
starting beon this week on my team let's
see what the good people at bleach
report have cooked up in the
gauntlet oh
golly so Kenneth
Walker has an incredible spot this week
mainly because Washington thinks that
they have Patrick Mahomes and so they
throw the ball on virtually every play
which slows the game down allows their
opponents to run a ton of plays and then
you get into this situation where they
gave they already had a terrible defense
they trade away montz sweat they trade
away Chase young so yes I will go
Kenneth Walker over I wouldit to The
Gauntlet Kenneth Walker over bejan no
Leon don't tell me you're starting bejan
over over Kenneth Walker no I'm starting
bean I mean this game's going to be a
little bit of a track me Dome game
against Arizona I mean sometimes you
just got to have faith bejan can you
know make enough plays I'm going bejan a
little bit worried about chbs you know
cutting into Walker's workload but yeah
you're wor you're worried you're worried
you're worried about it but we don't
have to worry about Tyler oir we know
Tyler oir is gonna play a ton anyways
just had to get that off my chest okay
go ahead Le oh no did did I did I
restart the gauntlet did I get it to
keep going because now because Aaron
Jones is up now so yeah we're going ban
baby uh bejan over Aaron Jones uh that's
fine I would still have
Walker I would have I would have these
Walker first then bejon then Jones then
then Derrick Henry uh for me so yes
Gauntlet I gave you the full breakdown
there let's get to some take a break
from The Gauntlet we'll do some q&as
here from chat we appreciate everyone in
chat who hangs out ask questions guy boo
says should I start CJ Moore and Cole KT
tonight so it's hard to see Tyson bent
supporting both of these guys right so
depending who's on your bench you may
want to try to split them up to try to
find some upside and also think about
how much ceiling you need in your lineup
I would prefer DJ Moore to KET but beun
has been targeting KT a ton in uh in the
goal line as well the only way you think
about this one djm or KT tonight or
maybe both yeah I mean assuming it's not
in a flex spot where you know you'd
clearly start DJ Moore I had a Kat I
think like position adjusted Kat's
probably the better play um just because
tight end's so gross out there um yeah
but I do think it's a spot where Chicago
is just going to run a ton like they're
actually favored with beet quarterback
they're facing one of the worst run
defenses in the league even though
they've been a little bit better
recently and yeah I just don't see a ton
of volume to go around here and a ton of
efficiency either in the Chicago passing
game B Baker asked Noah Brown oh I'm
sorry gb1 1974 asks chuba hubard or
naagi Harris so chuba has seemingly
taken control of this backfield hasn't
played particularly well but they think
he's better than my sanders this point
I'm pretty convinced about that if if
Chupa hubber comes out and actually
plays well I think he'll continue to
hold off my Sanders in a big way we know
the deal in Pittsburgh right now Nai has
his nose ahead of jayen Warren but it's
not by a lot what do you think about
this one
Leon I'm going to lean n here you know
the Steelers are three and a half Point
home favorites they've got a team total
in the low 20s whereas Carolina's in
like the mid High Teens there's a little
bit more touchdown equity for n Harrison
I do like him when Pittsburgh's expected
to play from ahead a little bit I think
that helps the split with Jaylen Warren
a bit more in his favor so um yeah n for
me B Baker says Noah brown or khil
Shakir in the flex Noah Brown I I had
pegged him as like a mere blocker when
he was on the Cowboys I never really
expected Noah Brown to be able to do
what Noah Brown did last week meanwhile
shakir's role has been solid ever since
Dawson Knox went down Cowboys this week
uh I'm sorry Texans this week have a
pretty good spot uh against the Bucks
bills also have a pretty good spot
against the Broncos what do you think
about this
one yeah I think I'd go to Noah Brown
here you know the bills Target shares
can get so concentrated that even though
Shakir has been good you know he's still
kind of like distantly behind whereas
you know the way CJ Stroud's playing
he's been able to spread it out to
everyone we also have Nico Collins on
the injury report which is something to
watch and that could further tilt things
in the favor of Noah Brown yeah sounds
like Nico Collins is in real danger of
missing this game MTM says Amari Cooper
or Chris Godwin so I'm not sure people
realize how good this Ravens defense has
been and they've been doing it like
without real stars on their team but
they have been
absolutely dominant meanwhile you know
the deal with Baker and Godwin you know
the bombs go to Mike Evans and these
little short passes go to Chris Godwin
what do you think about this one
Leone I think I'd go Godwin here you
know it feels like the boring selection
of the two since Amari Cooper can get
downfield a little bit more but as you
noted like that match up against
Baltimore is so tough whereas you know
Baker's got a pretty good matchup
against Tennessee that's a team that has
bad pass defense good run defense they
could throw a little bit more than you'd
normally expect in this game script and
it could be a little bit more successful
so I like Godwin over Amari
here Gaddy strong says tesm Hill or
George kill oh this is Leone's favorite
topic believe me oh when you try to
figure out what tesm hill is going to do
from a mathematical perspective that's
how you actually get Leon's brain to
explode because you cannot actually get
your head around Tamm Hill stuff around
the goal line it's really really hard to
figure out Tamm Hill could go eight
straight weeks without doing anything
because he's very touchdown dependent
that said George KD when everyone's
healthy we've seen him also go five six
weeks without doing anything at all I I
personally think I would almost always
play KD over taes regardless of the spot
but uh yeah I get it Hill's been
incredible lately what do you think Leon
yeah we we we've come too far to not
just say George K whe whether it's right
or wrong we're starting George KD here
at this point but uh in all seriousness
I think KD's the better floor and
ceiling option I think he's better on
both like like KD could have a three
touchdown like 150 yard game right like
I mean that that just blows out of the W
like even if taes has an awesome goal
line rle scores two touchdowns he's
still only getting you like 20 points
which is amazing but K get you 30 plus
fantasy points I got to go with the guy
that is one of the best tight ends in
the NFL one of the most efficient
passing offenses I'll live with the up
and down volatility with his raw
targets Leonardo says will Levis or Josh
dobs this week so a lot of people you
know have Jaylen Herz on a buy lost Kurt
Cousins whatever the thing about Josh
dobs is he has good Weaponry around him
even with Justin Jefferson out he still
has Addison still has
hackinson and he was running I mean he
was running for like 30 35 yards a game
on Arizona I think they'll continue to
encourage him to run in Minnesota
meanwhile the Lev stuff we already
talked about with DeAndre Hopkins what
do you think about this one
Leone I'm gonna go with dobs here I mean
both these teams have similar team
totals but you get dobs at home in the
dome and really you know the tiebreaker
just the rushan stuff you alluded to
like there's some uncertainty here um
and when there's that uncertainty like I
I don't know with lvis he threw the four
touchdowns out of the gate but he could
very easily you know I think his passing
yard prop lines like 215 220 yards like
that's not very high for a guy who's not
going to run a ton whereas dobs you know
he could run for 40 yards in a touch and
it's GNA be really hard for Levis to
compete unless he just has another one
of those outlier efficiency games ask me
next week you know maybe it's a
different answer if we see Levis show
out again but for right now uh you got
to go with the rushing floor of
dabs all right let's now get to the
fantasy bundle
presented by State Farm where bundling
your home and auto insurance is just
another way to save with the personal
price
plan I'll let you get to the first
bundle Leon since uh it fits your
laundry bro status go ahead on the first
bundle of the week and by the way for
those guys for anyone who's new uh
bundles we're referring to players who
fit well together if anybody plays DFS
out there that's kind of our our
specialty at establish the run and uh
yeah if you're playing tournaments you
want to be stacking quarterbacks with
their pass captures you want to at times
be stacking running backs with their
defense when it makes sense so go ahead
with our first bundle of the week
Leone yeah and if you think I'm a
laundry bro now uh just wait till the
Dalton concade Jersey I just ordered
gets delivered and then we'll really be
in position to answer this but yeah alen
concade I think there's a lot of like
murmurings about the bills offense
struggling they're a little bit
overblown they're top three-ish in like
almost any advanced offensive metric and
I think they found something here even
though the results weren't there last
week with Dawson Knox out where they
spread teams out a bit more I think
that's more beneficial to what Allen
does and Kade has really feasted you
know his highest two expected Fantasy
Point per game outputs were the last two
weeks he's averaged around 16 and a half
expected fantasy points per game had
only cracked double digits once before
then 18 combined targets three combined
Red Zone targets canade is starting to
look like you know one of the top tight
end options week in and week out moving
forward second bundle Gino Smith to
Tyler Lockett I already mentioned the
commander defense and how much I love
playing fantasy players against them so
I'm just going to try to lean into this
as hard as I can this week Gino has been
struggling I mean badly lately really
ugly in that game against the Ravens
that was like Rock Bottom this is like
the best possible spot now home against
the commander so Smith to lock it Smith
to DK meaf you're going to see more
voluming and you're also going to get
more efficiency out of Gino Smith here
Le only you can go to the third
bundle yeah third bundle is going to be
Tony Pard and the Cowboys defense
special teams there's always a strong
positive correlation between a running
back and the defense because if the
defense is performing well they're
giving good field position to the
running back it also leads to more
running plays for the offense which is
what we want and the Dallas defense is
in a spot to crush his 17-point
favorites against Tommy DeVito and the
Giants who have a poorest run defense
you know they're like bottom fiveish in
ftn dvoa metric right now and I know
Tony Pard has been really disappointing
I keep calling him a by low uh he's
remained a bu low because the stock
hasn't gone up yet but I think it's gon
to happen for him eventually this is a
really good spot too for Dallas to maybe
dial back the the really high Pass rates
they've shown the last couple of weeks
because they don't really need to in
this spot so I think it's a really good
get right spot for
Pard all right fourth bundle Brock pie
to Debo Samuel so when we last Saw Brock
pie before the 49ers by he made some
woeful throws I mean really really ugly
interceptions that cost his team the
game they were losing a ton Debo Samuel
wasn't healthy reset during the buy come
out of it get dbo back healthy and at
100% here for a game against the Jaguars
I expect the 49ers offense to return to
their Elite efficiency State here Brock
to Debo I think I prefer slightly over
Brock to iuk just on some of the Manzone
stuff but it's always really close
between those two guys Le only the fifth
and final bundle go
ahead yeah give me Joe burrow to Tyler
Boyd now the burrow side of this not
really a surprise Cincinnati has been
you know just full metal to the metal in
terms of the pass rate here they only
have one game below like a 65% pass rate
on the season which is outrages because
on a week- toe basis a team with a 65
plus percent pass rate projections like
one of our highest um of that particular
week and they are up there week in and
week out so I think with burrow healthy
and that pass right up there he's really
a high-end qb1 week in and week out what
we see with Tyler Boyd here though is
injuries to the Bengals pass catchers
you know that high pass rate the
volume's got to go somewhere Jamar Chase
got banged up decently in the Sunday
night game against Buffalo we think T
Higgins is probably going to be out
looks like he got hurt in practice this
week and Boyd is the most reliable
Target if there those guys do have
injury issues if they're out or if
they're
limited all right let's get to a couple
of your questions here quickly before we
wrap up with the gauntlet from Steel
City says for my Flex spot George
Pickins tank Dell or Demario Douglas so
I have Pickin concerns anytime Deontay
Johnson uh is playing because they just
stick him back on that boundary and make
him run those go routes so to me it
would be between tank Dell and Demario
Douglas I think if you want to play
aggressively and for ceiling like I
typically do it would be tankel pretty
easily for me there over de Douglas but
what do you think Leone on this
one I'm in line with you I think you got
to take the upside with Tink Dell
especially with Nico possibly out could
be a bit of a shootout between Houston
and Cincinnati lime Chase asks should I
start Kelvin Ridley or Z flowers and
yeah this this Baltimore Cleveland
matchup Adam I mean both these defenses
are just absolutely insane here um I
know flowers has been a bit more
consistent than Ridley but I actually
think Ridley has a decently higher
ceiling in this spot they're probably
going to have to throw a good bit
against San Francisco and San
Francisco's defense lowkey hasn't been
like that great I know I was doing some
of our projections this week kind of
approaching it as if they have a really
good defense and when you dig to some of
the advanced metrics it's kind of been
just neutral especially against the pass
I I like Calvin Ridley way more than Z
flowers this week and and yeah I think
that game has sneaky shootout appeal
49ers and jaguars all right let's get
Back Into The Gauntlet here
fourth guy through the gauntlet is going
to be Mr DK meaf in that spot against
the commanders going to be hard to get
me off this one let's see what producer
Ian has come up with
here yeah so glad you brought this up
Chris is a guy that I love I think is
awesome I think he's being misused by
the same
right now as Matt Harmon pointed out on
Twitter this week he's just not getting
any layup targets and it's really hard
similar to George Pickins you can be as
good as you want similar to Michael
Gallup when you don't get these targets
that are Slants stop routes screens
swing passes it's just hard for your
fantasy floor you're just asking a lot
on a week- toe basis and you're asking a
lot at a Derek Carr which he might not
be comfortable with so I will continue
to stick with DK meaf over Chris alive
here this
week oh Devonte Adams so what's going on
right now in Las Vegas is they're
starting Aiden oconnell and they're also
vocal about running the entire team
through Josh
Jacobs this is an impossible matchup for
Devonte Adams not impossible but really
hard Jets past events is awesome so I
will go with DK mchf still over Devonte
Adams this
week can DK make it all the way through
final
Gauntlet Mike Evans yeah I I like Mike
Evans this week we actually have him
about 0.4 ahead of DK Mecha this week
against the Titans or a bit or a real
pass funnel but man just this game
environment I want more pieces of this
Washington Seattle game environment so
I'll go ahead and stick with DK maaf all
the way through the gauntlet shout out
to DK Leon you can go ahead with the
fifth
Gauntlet all right DK makes it through
we will see a Bree hall for the New York
Jets makes it through I think this is a
pretty good spot for him uh with a
matchup against Las Vegas I'm always you
know the biggest concern with Bree Hall
is just how the offense overall is going
to go with Zach Wilson at the helm but
to get them in a dome neutral spread
against an opponent that's not as strong
vodes well for Hall who's really
commanding a extremely good chunk of the
running back touches
oh my goodness just out of the gate with
this Tony Pard stuff oh my goodness so
uh our projections right now have these
two projected extremely close to one
another I'm G to go Tony Pard here I'm
you know I think a little bit less
worried than the market on him bouncing
back and ultimately if it's close and
you're giving me the option to invest in
this Dallas offense that's going to
score a bunch of points against a really
bad opponent or invest in Zach Wilson I
have to go Tony Pard here even though I
do like breeze Hall quite a bit this
week all right final guy through the
gauntlet is a thinner one Mr Trey
McBride now big news for the Cardinals
this week Kyler Murray we're going to
see him for the first time in the 2023
season off of that ACL
that he sustained meanwhile Zack ZZ is
out and when Zack Herz is out we have
seen Trey McBride former macki Award
winner Trey McBride really show an
ability to earn targets and capitalize
on them so I think Trey McBride in the
spot against Atlanta with Kyler Murray
back and hers out is definitely a strong
streamer let's see who he's up against
here in The
Gauntlet David and joku so Browns are
using David and joku as like screen guy
and that's
been good because it raises floor a
little bit especially in full PPR but
it's hard to have really big games that
way now they're playing the Ravens in a
game we expect to be very low-scoring
and ugly I'll stick with the youngster
Trey McBride here over David and
joku oh Jake Ferguson so Jake Ferguson
has a really good role on Dallas I I
don't think people realize I mean Dallas
had so many weird games where the
defense has scored so much and they've
been winning by jakee Ferguson has
hasn't gotten to really spread his wings
until the last couple weeks where he
really really has was awesome against
the Rams until that game got it out of
hand and then was really good against
the Eagles again this one's tempting but
I'm gonna stick with Trey McBride here
on target
consolidation oh gosh dton Schultz this
guy Le only tried to get me to play dton
Schultz last week he tried he couldn't
he couldn't do it I had to play David
and joku instead I just couldn't listen
I had to play I couldn't play D schs guy
goes off for one of the biggest tight
end games of the Season yes Dalton
Schulz role right now is awesome and
Nico Collins might be out this week dude
is just playing really really well and
obviously CJ strout st's playing really
well also and I also think Houston at
this point is like we have CJ stoud we
have no Run game let's just throw the
ball you know yeah let's just throw it
and I think that's you know
uh in the range of outcomes for their
game plan to be another very very heavy
pass heavy attack so I will go with
Dalton Schultz over Trey McBride here to
end the
gauntlet to recap some guys we think
that are starts this week DeAndre
Hopkins DEA Douglas bejan Robinson DK
mcaf Bree Hall and Trey
McBride we got about five minutes left
here for some rapid fire Q a from chat
Tommy says tank Dell Jobe Meyers we like
tank Dell and especially with Nico
banged up and gosh I mean starting guys
against this Jets pass defense would be
really tough for me so I think that's a
pretty easy one there to be tank Dell
Leone will says Jameson Williams or
Michael Thomas we should note that
Donovan peoples Jones is expect to be
active for the Lions here which I don't
think it's great for Jameson Williams
what do you think about this
one yeah I think you got to go Michael
Thomas it's definitely the boring pick
of the two but the volume expectations
are so lopsided between the two I think
you need to see a little bit more out of
Jameson Williams before you throw him
out there Alvin says David Montgomery or
jir Gibbs jir Gibbs played very well
during daavid Montgomery's absence due
to a rib injury however now David
Montgomery is back I would personally go
David Montgomery because I think the
touchdown equity for him is so much
higher and lions rushing touchdown
Equity every week is amongst the highest
in the league they are the Run heaviest
team in the Red Zone in the entire
league and Dave Montgomery is the one
that they're going to use down there so
I think both are good starts here this
week but it would probably be
Montgomery for me there s g Le says
doson or
jsn I'll go doson here I mean this is a
fun game to attack Washington Seattle
but you know more confidence in
Washington really chucking it and also I
think you can make an argument for dson
being closer to like mclen right now
than you can to jsn you know leap
frogging locket and DK matf so I think
both are fine starts but I'll go
Dodson G3 says do I sit Devonte Adams
against the Jets pass defense and start
Tyler Boyd I probably would only do that
if both T Higgins and Jamar Chase are
out right now we have t Higgins out and
Jamar Chase Loosely projected in that
could change and if that changed I would
start Tyler boy otherwise I think you
have to stick with Devonte Adams here
last time we saw T Higgins out Tyler boy
only earned like 16% of the targets it
was incredibly tilting so yeah Chris
says Antonio Gibson or Keaton Mitchell
Keaton Mitchell the flavor of the week
this week Leone but already banged up on
the injury report what do you think
about this one Gibson or Keaton
Mitchell yeah he is banged up on the
injury report um this is a tough one
because I I don't think either of these
guys are a very good start so there's
part of me that just says like take the
uncertainty and play Mitchell in case he
has like an aan type of run here but
with him being on the injury rep I think
Gibson probably has the higher floor so
I guess it depends what you need if you
just need a handful of points play the
health of your body that's probably
going to catch more passes than Gibson
but if you're shooting for the moon then
you can go for Kean
Mitchell EDI says niik Collins or
Deontay Johnson I think it would be Nico
here against the pack uh Nico here
concerning Deontay Johnson against the
Packers uh if he's healthy but it
doesn't seem like niik Collins is
healthy so I think you got to go Deontay
Johnson there Raku Chu says Amari Cooper
Calvin Ridley or Jordan
Addison I think that's probably Ridley
for me Leone what do you think about
that one Cooper Ridley or
Addison I think it's Ridley for me as
well but uh we'll not in the projections
we have Addison and Ridley pretty close
um but I think with the uncertainty of
Dos at quarterback back I'd prefer
Ridley there yes speaking of Addison JS
1984 says Devonte Adams or Addison
obviously I understand it a lot of
people want to bench Devonte Adams this
week it's been a struggle and he's
facing the Jets what do you think about
this
one I think he's still got to play
Devonte Adams here I think he's too
talented to not play you know when we're
worried about Devonte Adams I think it's
relative to like the other really
high-end wide receiver ones or um
whatnot but this matchup with Addison
having some you know quarterback
concerns I'll I'll take Adams who I I
think he's GNA get force fed enough
targets is enough Talent by the goal
line to still do well even though you
know it's lower expectations than normal
for him ziby is in a quarterback
conundrum Gardner mshu or Derek Carr and
he or she also included a puke Emoji it
looks like I'm not one for emojis uh too
much but I think I know that one that is
the puke emoji that he or she included
Gardner or Derek Carr this
week I think I'd go Derek Carr uh you
know get the Dome game with about the
same team total I just think I I don't
know both these guys are at risk with
the touchdowns coming from other players
you know with the tesm hill risk with
Carr and then with mchu just how run
heavy that they can be I I think it's
close but um I'm going to lean Derek
Carr slightly here and also Josh DS is
probably gonna be out again for uh for
the Colts and he makes a difference for
them they don't have a lot behind
Michael Pitman in the past game Z
flowers or Quinton Johnson I don't know
if you answered this not or yet while I
was gone but people are ready to leave
Quinton Johnston forever like can't win
can't do it all I'll say about Quinn
Johnston is he is going to run a route
on like every justtin Herbert dropback
he may not be good enough to capitalize
on that it may be completely over for
him already as a rookie but he's going
to be out there a ton what do you think
about this
one yeah I mean Quinton Johnson should
be rostered everywhere right now just in
case he's able to flip a switch and it
happens uh with that said you know we've
got Z flowers even in the really
difficult matchup projecting two or
three points higher because you know the
target share that he's going to earn is
so much more secure than quiny Johnson
who you know just hasn't really been
able to get open and earn targets even
with the route share going up so far all
right that is going to do it for the
week 10 fantasy football show presented
by State
Farm be sure you're following all of us
on Twitter if you're serious about
fantasy football you have to be on
Twitter that's where all the best
information is Adam Levitan two hats1
Mike be sure you're following Bleacher
Report on Twitter also and I don't know
if you follow insurance companies but if
you do you might as well just follow
State Farm as well on Twitter C can't
can't hurt four Leon four producer Ian
and all the good people at bleacher
report for all our friends at State Farm
and everyone that establish the run I am
Adam good luck
everybody